i can't get the imagery out of my mind  of her having to bury her husband alone  and then pass in so soon after  it was surprisingly emotional given it  was a state funeral i think she's been  a wonderful monarch i think she you know  what she's done for the country is  unbelievable yeah  i didn't realize i would be upset  she's always been there she's been there  our whole lives  our parents lives our grandparents lives  and we're just we're never gonna we're  never gonna see that again it's really  it's upsetting it's so sad i just think  it's important that we'd be here and be  here as a community from manchester i  didn't want to watch it on my own at  home  so just wanted to come out and be part  of the manchester spirit